I'm curious for for your career going  forward you have done these huge movies  and I'm curious if you're interested in  um like doing something like a secret  Wars or another big Marvel project or  are you interested in doing like a  smaller more personal film yeah you know  what I mean yeah I mean look bro I'm I I  pray I have a uh  you know um  um I'm I'm a uh I'm a husband and a dad  now so I'm trying to live a long time  you know what I'm saying I hope to work  a long time  um and uh I love I love making movies it  brings me  it it fills me with um  a sense of joy that I hope every every  human can can find in their life and I  hope to make  I hope to I hope I can maintain that joy  and make more things of various sizes  um but truth be told like right like  right now I'm just focusing on this you  know and getting this done  um because it's because it's still a lot  of work to do before it comes out to the  world and um once that's over on my [ __ ]  and think about what's next